in 1968 the European customs union was
established in order to achieve a common
market within the European Economic
Community
1992 saw the consolidation of all
European customs legislation into one
regulation the community customs coat or
ccc over the years the law has been
refined EU member states coordinated and
enforced the law collectively but with
their own systems at the same time
international trade increased the EU
grew bigger technology developed at an
ever-increasing pace with electronic
transactions now than or and there was a
greater need for safety and security
considerations
the demand for supply chain efficiency
grew exponentially creating a greater
need to work even closer together and to
adapt more quickly to these changes
importers and exporters now have to deal
with 28 sets of data processing systems
which whilst largely aligned with each
other
could still be further harmonized may
2016 will see the introduction of the
union customs code or UCC a simplified
law that aims to facilitate trade to
decrease compliance costs for business
and sets how to implement more unified
electronic data processing techniques
from all exchanges of information
between trade and customs the UCC a
modern framework for customs and trade